Gmos are one of the most controversial areas of science.
Genetic engineering is used in many fields,
but even the medical applications like GM NCD now widely accepted the debate
heats up when it comes to food and agriculture.
Why is that?
Why is the same thing treated so differently?
Let's try to get to the bottom of this and explore the facts,
the fears and the future of Gmos.
Humans have been genetically modifying plants and animals for thousands of
years.
Maybe a few of your crops had very good yields.
Maybe one of your wolves who was especially loyal.
So you did the smart thing and bread,
the plants and animals that had traits beneficial to you.
Traits adjust an expression of genes.
So with each generation those genes got more pronounced.
After thousands of years,
almost every single plant and animal around us is vastly different from its pre
domesticated state.
If humans have been changing genes for millennia,
what makes a circle to genetically modified organisms or Gmos?
Different?
Selective breeding is basically hoping for lucky heads,
genetic engineering and lemonades.
This factor,
we can choose the traits we want,
make fruit grow bigger immune to pests and so on.
So why are people concerned about them?
Okay.
Netstock
with one of the most common objections to GMOs,
gene flow meaning GM crops could make us with traditional crops and introduce
the unwanted new characteristics into them.
There is a method that might guarantee complete prevention but it is a big anti
GMO argument by itself terminates the seeds.
The idea is that they could produce style plans requiring farmers to buy new
seeds every year.
The very concept of this however caused a public outcry,
stopping the technology being put to use.
This brings us back to the unintentional spreading of engineered DNA that have
been cases of GMOs growing where they weren't planted and traces of modified
genes found in foreign crops.
The GM plants can't run wild in tiny many crops pollinate them.
Sales and all crops have to be related to mingle.
There are also cultural methods like buffer zones to keep unintentional crossing
at a minimum,
but if it's possible in principle that a GMO could unintentionally crossed with
a non Gmo.
There's actually a more important question is food that comes from GM crops
different to food from non GM crops.
This question has been a major concern from the very beginning.
GM plants that are destined to be eaten are checked for possible and the results
are evaluated by multiple agencies after more than 30 years and thousands of
studies.
The science is in eating GMO plants is no more rescue than their non GMO
equivalent,
but don't just take our boy Fred sources for their sand.
Other claims are in the video description,
but what about plants that have been engineered to be toxic?
For example,
bt tropes,
a gene borrowed from the bacterium,
Bacillus Thuringiensis,
let's engineer plants produce a protein that destroys the digestive system of
specific in Sag past the plant makes its own pesticide insects that he tends to
die.
That sounds alarming.
Pesticide sprays can be washed off while the poison in bt crops is inside the
plant,
but actually it's not a big deal.
Poison is really just a question of different perspectives.
What's harmless to one species might kill another coffee,
for example,
is a poison that kills in but is harmless to us or take chocolate.
It's dangerous for dogs,
but a pleasure for humans.
Bt crops produce a protein that is tailored to the specific design of the
digestive tract of certain insects.
It's completely harmless for us.
There's also the opposite approach.
Plants that are engineered to be resistant to certain weed killers.
This way farmers can use them widely hitting the other plants competing for
resources without harming the crop.
Here we get to the dark underbelly of Gmos for the pesticide industry.
They are big business.
Over 90% of all cash crops in the u s are herbicide resistant mostly to
glyphosate.
As a result,
the use of glyphosate has increased gravy that isn't only bad force as much less
harmful to humans than many other herbicides.
Still,
this means farmers have a strong incentive to rely on this one method only
costing more Bannon's to ways of managing weeds or site.
That's one of the most fundamental problems with the GMO debate.
Much of the criticism of this technology is actually criticism of modern
agriculture and the business practice of the huge corporations that control our
food supply.
This criticism is not only van is it's also important.
We need to change agriculture to a more sustainable model.
Gmos as a technology are actually an ally and not an enemy in that fight.
Helping to save and protect leisure and minimize our impact on the environment.
Let's look at some positive examples.
That gland is an important crop in Bangladesh,
but often whole harvests are destroyed by pasts.
Farmers had to rely heavily on pesticides.
Not only was this very expensive,
farmers also frequently got sick.
The introduction of a new GM at gland in 2013 stop this,
the same bt protein we talked about before,
an effective killer of insects but harmless to humans was engineered into them.
This reduced insecticide use on eggplants by more than 80% the health of farmers
improves and their income rose dramatically and sometimes a GM approach is the
only option.
In the 1990s the Papaya industry in Hawaii was under attack from the ring spot
virus which threatened to wipeout Hawaiian Papaya.
The solution.
It was a Papaya genetically modified to be vaccinated against the virus without
it.
The states,
but by industry would have collapsed
all the stories,
so a very narrow application.
99% of all GMOs we use right now produce pesticides or are resistant against
them.
There is so much more we could do.
The scientists are working on Gmos that could improve our diet plants that
produce more or different nutrients like fruit with higher antioxidant levels
that help to fight diseases or rice with additional vitamins on a larger scale.
We're trying to engineer plants that are more resilient to climate change plans
that can better adapt to erratic weather and adverse soil conditions,
making them resistant to droughts or floods.
Gmos could also not only reduce agriculture's impact on the environment,
but actively helped to protect it.
The scientists are working on crops that can draw nitrogen from the air like
microbes.
Nitrogen is a common fertilizer,
but it's built up,
pollutes the ground water and speeds up climate change.
Plants that collect their own nitrogen could fix two problems at once.
The over use of fertilizers in the developed world as well as the shortage of is
in developing countries.
We could even modify plans to become super effective carbon collectors like the
American chestnut tree to mitigate and actually reverse climate change with the
tools we have today.
Our imagination is the limit.
The world eats 11 million pounds of food every day.
Hey,
you an estimate suggests will need 70% more by 2050 we could grow that food by
caring more and more for us to create fields and pastures and by using more
pesticides all we find a way to do it on the land we've got right now with more
effective methods like GM crops intensifying fobbing instead of expanding it
means Gmos could become the new organic.
In a nutshell,
Gmos have the potential to not only drastically changed agriculture,
but to also dampen the effects of our own irresponsible behavior.
Gmos could be our most powerful weapon to save our biosphere.
This video took more than 600 hours to make,
which would be impossible without viewer support on patrion.com if you'd like to
support carefully researched content made with love,
it's ready,
very helpful,
and you can get your own bird.
It's a reward.
If you want to learn more about genetic modification,
we have more videos explaining the yeah,
kinases and risks of the technology and how it could impact our future.